good news had a Dallas Texas tonight a
local salon owner her name's Shelly
Luther she was given a seven day jail
sentence fined $7,000 all because she
opened the doors to her business in
spite of quote the local lockdown orders
thank God today she was released from
prison after some support from the
governor lieutenant governor the AG at
Texas she joins us now
Shelley Luther thank God you're free how
are you doing I'm doing a lot better now
thank you so much when the judge said to
apologize we had your boyfriend on last
night said it reminded me of William
Wallace and Braveheart the prisoner
would like to speak a word you need to
apologize any to apologize to the
politicians I was like what I don't um I
think he was referring to clay Jenkins
the you know County Commissioner that
was the last thing I was going to do
honestly because the way that he has
acted during this entire thing is just
ridiculous so I just couldn't I couldn't
bring myself to apologize a good I
admire your courage how was Jail
well I'm sure wasn't Pleasant and I
heard this coronavirus in that jail it's
it's definitely not pleasant but
fortunately I had a cell by myself it
had a rec area that had other
individuals in there the worst thing was
that I didn't get to call anybody when I
got there the whole first night and
that's kind of scary because I have you
know a daughter that just turned 17 at
home and if my boyfriend wasn't there to
tell you know talked to her anything
I wouldn't have come home and she
wouldn't have known where I was that
that's that's pretty scary
um tell us why you decided to open and
what measures for safety did you take
well it wasn't I mean we were shut down
March 22nd so it had been several weeks
that you know the government was kind of
telling us the money was coming and the
actually this the Dallas County Judge
clay
clay Jenkins kept pushing back the date
of when we would open em weeks out in
advance before even you know hearing any
any new comings of what was going on
with masks or whatever and when he
finally pushed it back a final time I
just said I just woke up one day and I
said I have to open my stylists are
calling me they're not making their
mortgage I was at right now I still am
not caught up I'm two months behind on
my mortgage and my stylists were telling
me that they wanted to you know what do
you think if I go underground and go to
people's houses and I just said you know
that's not a good idea because we can't
control the environment there or we we
don't know if it's been a disinfected or
anything like that and I just decided I
would open to create a safe place for
the stylist and to make sure that I
wasn't the reason they weren't making
money which I had heard you did this
thing is real I'm in New York I see this
from a different perspective what we
have when you open were you all wearing
masks are you planning to wear masks how
do you plan on doing it please I saw
like I was actually impressed with
Georgia they put these nail salons they
have the plexiglass everyone's in class
masks and gloves we you were using all
that I heard mm-hmm yeah we weren't
using we tried to use the gloves at
first and that's kind of hard for the
hairstylist the nail techs of course did
but we made sure that I had no clients
waiting inside the salon at all so I had
chairs sit six feet apart outside of the
salon so we had no one waiting and when
a stylist was ready wearing a mask of
course we didn't let any clients come in
without a mask they instantly sanitize
their hands the hairstylist sanitized
their hands and they came in they did
the cut and that person left and with a
mask there were no magazines in there
are no drinks
yeah everybody had to wear a mask to
come in how many people work for you
they don't work for me but I usually
have about 19 stylists in there at a
time I'm gonna make a donation to your
shop I want you and your workers to at
least get over the hump if you can pass
that on or our producers I'm sorry
you've had to go through that I'm glad
you're free and we're praying that every
pitting can open safely soon and you
showed a lot of courage or you're an
inspiration thank you much